le 78 sur TV file à présent avec le
point sur l'actualité sportif dans les
evelines et ce weekend les Templiers ont
chuté en finale de 2e division et oui
les Templiers d' lancour ont rencontré
les kangourous de Pessac en jeu le titre
de champion de France de D2 des
illusions pour les Templiers qui se sont
inclinés 3730 au terme d'un match à le
temps il faut le souligner nous en
parlerons dans un instant avec George
Agostinho qui est le président des
templier bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir à vous
et puis nous avons aussi en ple Vincent
couteau et Stéphane salvari bonsoir à
tous les deux vous êtes chargé de
mission la base de loisir de trappe et
on évoquera l'atelier sportif de cet été
pour le moment Adrien du tennis plus
précisément ce sont les collégiens qui
vont pouvoir suivre cette discipline dès
la rentrée et oui le tennis au cœur des
collèges yvelinois dès l'année prochaine
c'est l'objet de cette réunion à Roland
Garros cet après-midi qui réunissait
chefs d'établissement scolair des
ivelines la Ligue de tennis
départemental et l'académie de
Versailles l'expérience qui fonctionne
très bien dans les écoles primaires
permet aux enfants de couvrir le tennis
et de le pratiquer gratuitement avec
leurs professeurs alors pour les
collèges les jeunes pourront sur le
temps scolaire ou après les cours
pratiquer ce sport encore absent des
programmes on va écouter tout de suite
l'inspecteur de l'académie de Versailles
Jean-Michel Coignard et Norbert rampola
président de la ligue de tennis des
Yvelines le but est de faire découvrir
ou mieux découvrir mieux
appréhender les gestes qui fondent le
tennis libre ensuite à chacun d'avoir sa
pratique sociale sportive nous l'idée
c'est qu'il découvre l'ensemble des
possibilités d'un sport et de tous les
sports le tennis rentre dans ce cadre et
on fait un effort particulier sur lui
c'est un investissement qui doit séduire
les jeunes dans les collèges pour
pouvoir créer dans un futur je dirais
une compétition de
collège par équipe voir en individuel et
ça sera vraiment très interne au
collège de retour sur le plateau de ce
78 pour évoquer le football américain
donc et oui donc on en revient à cette
rencontre contre les Kang gourou de
Pessac à à l'extérieur donc c'était chez
eux à Bordeaux c'était sûrement la
dernière défaite de l'année c'était
peut-être la plus difficile il a plus le
match après alors c'est facile voilà
c'est ça c'était sûrement la dernière
défaite même si défaite elle
a on va appeler ça une défaite parce
qu'on n pas gagné le titre mais au terme
de la finale on était a zeco 30 à 30 ça
s'est joué dans les dernières secondes
euh non au terme au terme de la finale
on était vraiment à 30 30 oui ça s'est
joué dans les dernières secondes de la
rencontre puis qu'il y a eu non il y a
eu ce qu'on appelle chez nous un
overtime il y a eu comme les penalties
au
foot le la mort subite qui a voilà nous
on était on était à 30 à 30 à la
mi-temps donc le match est fini puis
voilà puis on a perdu sur un coup de
hasard mais c'était une très très belle
finale il y Ava eu beaucoup de monde il
faisait beau on a fait un B match bon on
a eu 15 15 minutes pour se remettre de
la perte du titre mais bon ça reste
malgré tout une belle expérience un bon
match alors vous êtes tombé sur plus
fort que vous c'était sensiblement
équilibré parce que quand même euh vous
étiez quand même l'année dernière en
élite euh là vous avez survolé la la 2e
division euh là c'est une rencontre
c'était un match important avec en jeu
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
comment analyser C ces trois défaites
puisqueil y en a bon euh peut-être une
une de trop dans le on va pas refaire
tout le tout le comment comment
pourrait-on comment comment pourrait-on
analyser cette défaite puisque c'est
quand même assez préoccupant peut-être
de se dire de de rater ces matchs à en
jeu ouais oui oui sûrement euh dans
toutes des faes on va tirer tout ce qui
a tiré on va essayer de de ne pas
renouvler les mêmes erreurs chose qu'on
a du mal à faire actuellement parce que
effectivement on rentre très très mal
dans nos matchs le premier quart temp on
on a toujours du mal après bon sur ce
match bien précis on avait un bel
adversaire qui lui est resté sur sur une
saison parfaite ils ont sont à 13
victoires sur sur 13 matchs ils vont
jouer en élite donc ils ont le niveau
d'élite ils ont joué le match de barrage
ils ont battu une équipe d'élite donc on
considère qu'ils sont au niveau d'élite
donc on avait un futur très bon club
d'élite en face de nous ça c'est prouvé
on a fait il y a 5 minutes du match on
était devant bon après bah c'est du
sport heureusement hein alors on voit
des images en cours de saison c'était
pas les images de la finale mais c'est
en cours de saison globalement ce que
vous rappelez Adrien il y a eu trois
défaites dans cette saison ces trois
défaites qui sont dues à quoi un manque
de concentration dans les derniers
instants vous l'avez dit là sur la
finale pour le titre ça s'est joué après
le temps réglementaire don ça s jou
vraiment sur la fin les joueurs étaient
déjà en
vacances ils ne sont pas passés à côté
de leur match ça c'est quelque chose cé
trand même bien j c'était B ils avaient
TR trois tentatives pour marquer un
essai ils l'ont marqué nous on en a eu
trois on na pas marqué donc on a pas
d'autres tentatives pour essayer de se
rattraper c'était comme ça av ils ont
marqué ça s'est joué quoi ça s'est joué
au mental ça s'est joué dans les têtes
sur C sur ces momentsl ch sur une action
bien précise ils ont marqué la fatigue
peutêtre aussi non ils étaient aussi
fatigués que nous je pense non non ça
s'est joué ils ont fait un très bon jeu
nous on n pasussi cont de vos joueurs on
est content il y a pas de problème en
tout cas ça reste une saison ça reste
une saison quand même relativement bonne
plutôt plutôt même excellente ouais pour
si réussi qu'on aurait qu'on aurit
espéré parce que on voulait non
seulement gagner ce fameux match de
barrage et et gagner cette finale donc
bon on n'est pas passé loin c'est pas
grave il y a pas il y a pas un gros
écart non plus donc il a des choses à
corriger malheureusement on on a encore
joué sans américains nos deux derniers
matchs contrairement à l'équipeadverse
on a pas de chance mais c'est comme ça
quoi justement ce fameux match de
barrage vous étiez venus en plateau nous
en parlez déjà ce match de barrage vous
l'avez perdu c'était la deuxième défaite
il y en a eu trois l'impression qu'on
parle que des défaites des templi mais
ils ont gagné cette saison aussi on a
parlé des victoires cette on a gagné 10
quand même voilà mais c'est les moments
clés donc en tout cas sur ce match de
barrage vous l'avez perdu en revanche
l'inconnu c'était de savoir si oui ou
non la Fédération allait accepter votre
appel vous aviez interpellé la
Fédération sur le fait que l'équipe
adverse et fait rentrer pendant le match
un joueur américain qui n'avait pas joué
plus de 5 rencontres au cours de la
saison et donc il ne pouvait pas
participer normalement sur le tapis vert
normalement vous avez gagné ce match
qu'en est-il aujourd'hui est-ce que la
Fédération vous a répondu officiellement
non officieusement oui officieusement
pas tout à fait on a rencontré des gens
ce weekend de la fédération qui
soutenaient enfin de toute façon le
règlement il est très clair donc qu'on
dev pouvez dire ce soir les Templiers
devraient selon toute vraemblance voilà
on va le dire comme
ça off donc il y a rien mais on a était
soutenu dès le début en disant
effectivement ils ont fait ils ont
essayé quelque chose qui n'était pas
très très réglementaire ils ont joué ils
ont jouer bah donc ça devrait être
officiel au cours de de la semaine les
Templiers qui devrait pouvoir retrouver
retrouver l'élite la première division
malgré cette défaite et puis pour le
match de barrage et puis la défaite pour
pour le titre ça va changer un petit peu
votre optique pour le recrutement pour
la saison prochaine le fait d'être
quasiment assurer maintenant de jouer en
division en première division il va
falloir partir à la pêche au sponsor
maintenant la pêche au sponsor faire
venir des joueurs des encadrements et
tout ben oui oui oui c'est une autre
préparation que une préparation des deux
effectivement est-ce que vous irez
chercher des des joueurs étrangers
l'année prochaine également bien sûr
bien sûr vous avez déjà des noms ou des
des pistes non encore ça se fait
toujours on a rencontré sur notre route
lors de quelques joueurs qui étaient
intéressant tu av rencontré beaucoup de
monde ce weekend c'était pas ce weekend
cétait en l'occurrence un match au
moment où il y a un très bon joueur qui
nous a bien qui nous a bien fait des
misères sur les matchs qu'on a joué
contre lui donc c'est un américain très
B américain il se peut qu'on rentre en
contact avec lui donc on a on a donc
plusieurs pistes qu'on va on a tout
l'été pour travailler ces pistes là mais
on va se faire effectivement comme comme
chaque club en élite on a droit à deux
Américains vous votre équipe pour
éventuellement ça sera confirmé cette
semaine jouer en première division l'an
prochain c'est peut-être l'information à
retenir je l'aurais presque fait dire on
continue avec votre programme en tout
cas samedi 30 juin il y a un rendez-vous
oui samedi 30 juin du club ah exact vous
êtes courant vous avez lancé vous l'avez
vous avez lancé un appel pour tous les
jeunes nés entre 93 et 95 à venir
découvrir le football américain donc
est-ce que vous êtes en en en demande
d'effectif pour se faire un bon vivier
de jeune dans dans le club donc
l'effectif on a on a un très bon
effectif en cadet des 13 16 ans ils sont
plus de 85 87 licenciés donc voilà on a
un petit trou dans junior qui est
vraiment une section un peu spéciale
c'est des gamins de 17 19 ans et là on
était un peu en sous- effffectif donc on
va faire une journée de recrutement
effectivement au complexe sportif de
l'Europe de 14h à 18h 18h à peu près et
puis à 18h après il y aura la fête du
club la fête de fin de saison comme on
fait tous les ans qu'on va récompenser
les les MVP comme on dit chez nous
parction et puis on se prend un petit
coup manger une mergaz et puis voilà ce
sera samedi 30 juin si vous voulez aller
manger une mergaaz avec les Templiers
vouserez bienvenue pour découvrir le
football américain initiation donc à
partir de 14h pour pour les plus jeunes
samedi merci George Agostino et puis
dans un instant nous verrons avec nos
autres invités de cette page sport
comment occuper votre été à la base de
loisirs à trappe pour l'instant Adrien
on continue avec les résultats sportifs
l'autre actualité du weekend c'était la
revancheard c'est du cyclisme en cours
c'est même plus que du cyclisme c'est du
VTT donc c'était la c'était la deuxième
manche du Challenge vélo toutterrain
Tour 2012 et donc l'épreuve tout de
suite en image sur la colline
deslancour 14e édition de la
revanchearde sur la colline des lencour
c'était ce dimanche la deuxème manche du
Challenge vélo tout terrain Tour 2012 au
profit des orphelins des apport pompiers
de France 140 participants se sont
élancés sur un tout nouveau circuit on
est sur vraiment une épreuve maintenant
très très technique beaucoup plus
qu'avant et on a privilégié un peu le le
spectacle pour les familles à chaque
tour chaque concurrent monte trois fois
en haut de la colline ce qui provoque
des meilleures sensations pour les
concurrents et une meilleure visibilité
pour les
familles une boucle de 11 km que les
VTTistes ont parcouru trois fois des Cid
des descentes à pique un beau parcours
en perspective j'ai jamais fait de
course de cross country donc je vais
voir un peu à quoi ça ressemble quoi il
y a une côte qu'il faudra faire à pied
sans doute voilà une côte qui est très
raide que j'ai vu avant donc
psychologiquement je me suis apprêté à
marcher c'est un entraînement et puis
c'est c'est pour enfin avoir une course
pour s'entraîner au départ et à
l'endurance j'ai pas beaucoup préparé à
cause du bac mais on verra bien et c'est
tout vu pour Camille galato qui s'est
imposé chez les femmes et chez les
seniors c'est Cédric Chartier quatre
fois vainqueur de l'épreuve 3000 € ont
ainsi été récoltés pour les orphelins
des sapeurs pompiers la suite de cette
page sport du lundi dans le 78 sur TVfil
toujours en direct si vous nous suivez
entre 18 et 19h c'est avec la base de
loisirs de trappe qui va nous annoncer
son programme pour l'été on peut faire
du sport à la base de loisir pendant les
vacances on peut faire beaucoup beaucoup
de sport Beach volet beach rugby pétank
piscine à vague bodyboard d' aathlétisme
et j'en passe avec nous pour en parler
Vincent couteau et Stéphane salvari
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir on commence par
parler sport de plage avec la 6e édition
du de l'opération Beach au soleil alors
en quoi ça consiste et ça dure tout
l'été tout à fait alors tout à fait
c'est c'est une opération donc qui va
débuter avec l'ouverture de la piscine
le 7 juillet jusqu'au au 2 septembre
donc nous accueillons sur le site de la
piscine tous les T tous ceux qui ont
envie de d'avoir autre chose que la
baignade donc on met des animations en
place on travaille avec certaines
féd donc on aura le volet qui sera
présent le handbal avec le sbal et puis
le rugby qui seront présents sur le le
Beach au soleil nous avons nos propres
animateurs puisque nous proposons aussi
des activités comme la pétanque le
Speedball euh la PTK et cetera et cetera
voilà donc tout l'été on peut faire
beaucoup de sport pk ça m'interpelle
c'est quoi alors la PTK c'est c'est un
sport brésilien euh c'est un énorme
volant de badminton et on on n pas de
raquette on joue avec ses mains avec ses
pieds avec sa tête voilà pas besoin
d'être un sportif confirmé non du tout
c'est pour tous les niveaux alors il y a
aussi forcément la piscine àague qui va
qui va rouvrir et il y aura un
simulateur de surf et de bodyboard que
vous avez installé cette annéeétait pas
là l'an dernier il y avait un autre
simulateur mais c'était pas celui-ci
voilà complètement l'an dernier nous
avions un simulateur de skiutique et de
we surtout cette année donc nous nous
avons essayé de d'avoir un un autre
appareil donc c'est un une autre
dimension euh donc il est arrivé la
semaine passée nous l'avons jusqu'au 23
septembre il est devant la piscine il
est pas à l'intérieur il est devant la
piscine et là on peut pratiquer sur une
vague
artificielle le surf et le body surf il
a été testé lors du défin nature
absolument il a été ouvert pour le
définat ouais tout à fait alors si ça ne
suffisait il y a aussi un village DT
pour les jeunes du 9 juillet au 10 août
quelles activités seront proposées à ce
moment-là si vous en avez d'autres
rajouter alors il y en a encore une
multitude on pourrait parler pendant des
heures de la base de loisir donc
effectivement ce ce village d'été euh il
consiste à
accueillir des
jeunes donc là j'ai est relativement
vaste pu c'est c'est 11 17 c'est ça euh
donc tous les jours du lundi au vendredi
sur une multitude d'activités qui vont
être l'acrobranche la voile ou le canoé
euh le badminton on va avoir aussi du
VTT euh on aura des initiations au geste
qui sauve également euh donc là du du
lundi au vendredi de 10h à 17h comment
vous faites le choix de de toutes ces
activités justement c'est calibré en
fonction des demandes aussi des des
utilisateurs de la base de loisir alors
tout à fait donc là nous avons mis en
place un un programme donc on a des
créneaux ouvert en fait pour tous les
jours et bah les les les jeunes via leur
structure peuvent s'inscrire sur des
créneaux ici donc faire par exemple
acrobranche le matin et et badminton
l'après-midi voilà en tout cas mixer
leur carte de cette façon est-ce que
tout ça est gratuit ça coûte combien
tout est gratuit pour le ce village
d'été effectivement voilà donc c'est mis
en place par la par la région
î-de-france qui finance le projet
combien de visiteurs vous accueillez
chaque été parce que là avec toutes ces
activités vous devez avoir beaucoup de
monde visiteurs sur la piscine ou sur
l'ensemble de la base sur l'ensemble de
la base l'été c'est difficile de d'avoir
un chiffre précis sur la
piscine on va dire envir environ 40000
mais ensuite sur le reste de la base
entre toutes nos activités je pense
qu'on on fait au moins on double au
moins ce chiffrec facile sachant que
vous êtes forcément tributaire de la
météo ça ça n'ide pas et surtout
concernant la piscine à vague sachant
qu'il y a eu des investissements très
lourds qui ont été fait ces dernières
années pour justement faire venir le
public tout à fait et cette année encore
nous avons encore réalisé des travaux
sur la piscine puisqu'il ils sont pas
encore tout à fait terminés donc depuis
c'est la 4e saisonù nous faisons des
investissements très lourds sur la
piscine pour améliorer donc la qualit
d'accueil cette année nous avons encore
travaillé sur du carrelage de la piscine
en machinerie et puis nous avions un
petit défaut sur la piscine beaucoup
nous reprochaient d'avoir le côté nature
d'avoir trop de lapin sur la
piscine donc voilà nous avons lapin
voilà donc nous avons cette année
travaillé sur un grillage antilapin pour
éviter c'est c'est surprenant pour une
piscine voilà donc sur la plage en tous
les cas pas sur la piscine mais sur les
sur les espaces verts il y avait
énormément de lapin beaucoup de trous de
terriers donc voilà on avait quelques
petites remarques dessus donc on a
essayé de voilà encore une fois de de de
bah de de se rapprocher de ce que nous
demandaient nos nos usagers alors j'ai
un dernier mot aussi à vous faire dire
c'est sur cette opération cinéma plein
air le 7 juillet je crois ouais alors là
c'est une date vraiment à noter dans vos
agendas donc on a deux opérations
cinémaapinire la première c'est le le 7
juillet la deuxème le 25 août euh en
fait ça consiste à à faire profiter de
de cet espace donc de la piscine
chauffée je précise puisque donc on a
changé les pompes àchur aujourd'hui on
est une à 26°gr en permanence et donc
l'opération commence à 18h c'est 3 € par
personne et donc c'est bignat de 18h à
21h30 ensuite la cafétria reste ouverte
où vous pouvez amener votre propre
pique-nique et derrière c'est l'âge de
glasse 3 en 3D donc on été les premiers
anné dernière à faire du du ciné plinire
3D donc on reconduit expérience et le 25
août ce sera Buenavista ass club donc
les chanteurs les musiciens cubains euh
donc le film sur les musiciens cubin en
tout cas qui qui sera diffusé à cette
occasion pour ce cinéma en plein air et
attention au lapin même la nuit sorte la
nuit paril les lapins merci à tous les
deux d'êtreevenu Adrien un dernier Moot
dernier résultat sportif je va pas vous
parler de lapin je par parler de cougard
les cougards de Montini c'est du
baseball qui se sont imposés contre
Savini 9-3 et 15-2 dimanche dernier donc
hier au classement Montini et 2è
derrière chartre alors le programme des
play-offs ça y est on l'a c'est le 1er
juillet à chartre le 8 juillet à
dkererque et il faudra attendre le 2
septembre pour voir les cougar jouer à
domicile ça sera contre Montpellier
merci Adrien on vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour une nouvelle page sport et
puis malgré une météo peu clémentante ce
weekend la fête de la musique a une
nouvelle fois été un succès nous étions
sur le site de la batterie à Guill
encours samedi soir SEP scènes ouvertes
avec des groupes amateurs une soirée que
nous résument Maxime lemen et Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
ambiance jazz ambiance grovy ambiance
funky ce soir à la batterie alors c'est
pas mal en guise d'introduction mais moi
je vous propose de passer tout de suite
à quelque chose de beaucoup plus rock
and roll le rock and roll c'est
justement le thème qu'avait choisi
Jean-Pierre Pia et son équipe pour fêter
la musique pour faire leur fête de la
musique en décalé alors pourquoi le
choix de ce thème c'est la question que
nous lui avons posé c'est
[Musique]
parti simplement parce que nos groupes
qui répètent ici dans nos studios sont
majoritairement des groupes pop rock et
donc à près de 80 % donc évidemment ça
se ressent sur les plateaux que l'on
l'on propose ce soir il y a un petit peu
de tout beaucoup de classique rock un
peu de pop rock aussi ça dépend aussi
des générations faut dire qu'on touche
vraiment aussi dans nos studios toutes
sortes de génération le rock bah c'est
maintenant très ancien voilà la pop fête
aussi son anniversaire aujourd'hui
[Musique]
voilà autant de style que d'interprète
et quand on demande aux spectateurs si
le rock leur évoque quelque chose chacun
y va de sa
référenceri ZEP plutôt dans les années
60 70 le rock de la musique qui bouge la
musique avec beaucoup d'instruments la
guitare
[Musique]
électrique CDC Metallica volbeit les
Beatles un peu de tout Rolling Stones
aussi voilà pour moi parce que je suis
pas un adepte particulièrement de cette
musique c'est plutôt une
époque les années 70 la grande liberté
les barrières qu'on fait tomber et tout
ça ouais bon je pense que ça mérite
d'être clair en tout cas quel que soit
le style l'origine ou l'interprète les
spectateurs présents samedi soir à la
batterie ont eu l'occasion de s'en
mettre plein les oreilles
[Musique]
écoutez